[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see what's making
those headlines then with the daily
mirrors associate editor Kevin McGuire
and the Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine
welcome and great to see both of you
front pages though let's kick off shall
we with
the Metro amid suggestions that Thames
water could collapse the Metro describes
the company as on the brink here's the
guardian the headline crisis talks as
Thames water faces 10 billion pound
deficit according to the eye taxpayers
in this country could be called upon to
bail The Firm out despite it having
stakeholders in China and Abu Dhabi the
telegraph says that whole swathes of the
UK water industry may have to be taken
back into public ownership
Daily Mail reports that doctors planning
to go on strike for more than for more
NHS pay will still be allowed to do
private work on stoppage days
a source quoted in the express warns
that the government will fight members
of the House of Lords who are against
its proposed laws to stop small boats
and the star tells us that the king
isn't a fan of slugs
I could talk about slugs for a good half
hour but I won't you'll be glad to know
anyway reminder scan that QR code you
can check out those front pages for
yourself while you listen to our guests
so let's head straight to Kevin McGuire
and Sarah Vine
um yeah that was about this time last
night that our City Engine Mark Kleinman
broke the news about Thames water Kevin
um but it's it's been picked up we know
the chancellors had meetings today and
really the question now is what what
next for Thames for customers and indeed
for other water companies if you look at
those headlines
no absolutely Thames they uh the
country's biggest water provider 15
million customers has 14 billion uh debt
mattresses that's 80 of the value of the
chief executive Sarah Bentley's gone uh
and this is a genuine crisis got the
government saying it'll keep the Taps
running but what happens because I think
water privatization in England they're
all monopolies there's been a disaster I
think the overall figure is 1989 zero
debt when they were private owned by the
Thatcher government now they've got 54
billion debt they've run up debt and
over the same period the financial times
are saying they've given out 72 billion
in dividends to shareholders so what
happens next government steps in does it
uh does it do what I think it should
really really happen it will be hugely
popular uh nationalize the entire uh
industry I think there's a yoga of Paul
showed 69 of people think that should
happen more to be better in the public
sector only eight percent uh not or does
it then try and find a a new buyer but
this is a real crisis in a in a
privatization that I think has been a
disaster yes and one of the architects
of that thatcherite sell-off today said
you know it was deliberately designed at
the time to be extremely attractive you
know to both investors and and uh you
know the the British people buying
shares but that wasn't meant to continue
and it does seem that there's been an
over over generous dividends being paid
over generous salaries been paid Sarah
you're nodding there
um and there seems to be some sort of
Creative Accounting that's been going on
and a failure of Regulation so it feels
like this is sort of you know deep into
the mire actually for the water
companies
yeah well it feels like someone's been
asleep on the job the regulator because
apart from anything else these companies
have been pumping loads of I mean their
Thames water has one of the worst uh
water wasted records of any company and
flooding and just generally mismanaging
the whole system I mean Thames water is
is my supplier and it's just it's just
it's a disaster it's expensive they
charge you through the nose for it and
and as far as I can tell they they're
just incompetent I mean Kevin is right
it's a real
um
I mean it's just really it doesn't say
much for privatization does it because
you know this is this whole this whole
system has just been basically there for
um you know shareholders investors to
just take money you know just literally
just to sort of they've just raped it as
far as I can see I mean the amount of
money that it owes is just astonishing
really when you think about it there's
always been quite a lot of sympathy for
Thames you know it's Victorian system
you know the sewage Works under London
you know or a massive amount of
investment needed but it seems to be the
owner before the current owners of
Thames that cause part of the problem
here Kevin
um but but it you know is the days of
our sympathy that I listed you know I'm
talking decades back probably for that
is that long gone if they had plenty of
cash to sort this out or do these
companies need propping up anyway
no they've been given it out to
shareholders rather than in investing it
I mean people pay here rather a lot for
their water bills regularly go and buy
more than in inflation when they say
it's a Victorian system well you know
roads and footpaths go uh are older than
Victorian systems often and you don't
get the same complaints there's no doubt
that needs to be investment but it it
hasn't happened uh soon enough and if
they just spent more money on investment
instead of siphoning off profits uh
maybe we wouldn't be in this this mess
now I think Thames deserves no uh
sympathy at all they've rinstos uh Sarah
Sarah says and now it's coming out the
roost I just hope we don't see the
losses are nationalized and you know
profits are always privatized it's it's
water is a it's a monopoly in any area
so if you privatize it you would have to
have the toughest regulation over it but
it's easier and simpler and better just
to run it as a public service in the
public sector but like rail yeah the
losses and nationalized question makes
the front of a number of papers the
guardian we saw there the government it
says has no true grasp and on the costs
involved in preventing a collapse of
Thames water with estimates presented to
ministers and Regulators suggesting the
company could face a whole of 10 billion
pounds in its finances obviously it's
going back to its investors at the
moment and the eye says that UK
taxpayers could bail out the failing
water firm which is
um partially owned by China and Abu
Dhabi
um you know Nations that have Stakes uh
in in Thames water
um so as Kevin said you know you get the
losses being nationalized in in issues
like this can be bad knock made it quite
clear she was desperate to see this
entity survive as she put it today Sarah
yeah I mean the point is that China I
mean China is a hostile state it should
not have a stake in our major London
supply of London and Southeast water
company I mean what I don't understand
how it could how could how could be in a
situation where China and Abu Dhabi own
our water supply for London it's just
insane some or somewhere along the line
something really serious has gone badly
wrong
which the eye suggests has been urged to
shore up the firm and Safeguard
consumers
um you know and Abu Dhabi as well you
know I mean China has it had it had its
hand in a lot of companies did it not in
terms of infrastructure and that was
that was the the concern recently
yes
sorry Kevin
sorry Sarah yeah I mean absolutely we
were going to ask them to build a
nuclear power station they're in they're
in telecoms now not all of it is is uh
is bad but I just think it's it's a
weird world we we live in we're in Abu
Dhabi China and could mention Canadian
Pension funds too or ironing water
companies
uh that uh in danger of going bust
uh it's just it's just a complete not a
mess I can say one Cami uh wants it to
survive as an entity because she hopes
she doesn't have to uh get her hands
dirty as she will see it and she'd
certainly be against just ideologically
against taking it over even for a short
period of time that's just not that's
not her economics she's all hands off
that's right economic but I'm afraid
it's just quite clear it hasn't worked
with water there are many parts of the
economy that are very Lively and vibrant
and dynamic in the private sector
but water is not one of them well the
the telegraph goes even further uh
suggesting that Whitehall um was
creating contingency plans to
nationalize swathes of Britain's water
industry
um as the country's biggest supplier
cheated on the brink of collapse a
rescue deal could yet be agreed
um but the suggestion is that there are
fears that the collapse could trigger a
domino effect across the industry which
is Laden with 60 billion pounds of debt
built up during years of lower interest
rates and it does appear it is inflation
and interest rates which are causing
this issue at the moment Sarah too
well yes I mean low interest rates have
been a sort of have been a you know a
kind of fake thing for so long and
they've got lots of people in trouble
um and and you know these companies
should really have known better I mean I
they've obviously been grotesquely
mismanaged because and used just as as a
sort of Leverage tool for people for the
shareholders to reap dividends and
that's you know this is water we're
talking about people can't just not have
water it's not as Kevin says it's a
monopoly it's not something that you can
live without you know you you can you
could go off grid with your electricity
I suppose but you can't with water you
need to have water it's a basic human
right so the idea that that these
companies have been borrowing low
interest borrowing huge sums of money
not investing in the infrastructure
because we know this because the thing
is full of leaks and is always breaking
down and endless sort of sewage being
pumped into rivers and seas and and now
they're in debt and they're coming to
the tax pair with the with their cap and
hand no that's absolutely not under no
circumstances
well uh Thames water obviously said um
today that it was continuing to work
with its shareholders as it sought more
funding for its turnaround plan so we we
watch and wait and see what happens but
let's move on to Sarah I'm going to stay
with you if you don't mind because
you've written about this week this week
in your column
um this is the Metro
um picking up on Daniel corski the Tory
mayoral hopeful who'd been accused and
denied grouping a TV producer has
decided to step away from that race
because it was a distraction your
thoughts
an interesting story because
the accusation is
um and some of your listeners will know
this because they will have listened to
radio and the TV throughout the course
of the day but the acquisition
accusation is is that 10 years ago uh a
TV producer was invited to number 10 to
discuss an idea for a show and Dan
Gorski who was then a sort of quite sort
of senior or very senior spad actually
under Dave Cameron
um flirted with her throughout the
conversation and then as she got up to
leave he touched her breast and the uh
she said what she what on Earth do you
think you're doing and he sort of
stopped and that was the end of it
anyway she wrote about it uh not naming
him I think seven or eight years ago and
anyway she's now named him and as a
result he has uh stood down
um and it's it's caused I mean it's
interesting because
um I've talked to lots of people about
this today and there sort of seems to be
two camps one which is uh he's he's a
disgusting sexual pervert he shouldn't
be running for mayor of London and the
other is well it was a mistaken or a
Bosch's attempt at flirtation or
seduction or whatever and it was 10
years ago and you know
he did stop when she told him to stop
and so why is this man's life being
completely destroyed I mean what's
interesting about it is it it it's it's
very much a story for the Times isn't it
because
this happens a lot to uh men doesn't
really happen to women but predominantly
men you know they get to a certain point
in their careers and then someone comes
after Woodwork and says you know
historic sexual accusations there's no
proof because at the time she didn't
report the incident
um it's just a question of who you
believe he denies everything
um she insists that it happened who are
we supposed to believe and the
prevailing wind is believe the woman
because you know women are off not
believed in these circumstances but I
also personally don't think that it's
entirely Fair uh for someone to have
their entire sort of life's work
destroyed because that's what is going
to happen to him I mean I had no idea
whether he would have made it good or
bad London mayor that's that sort of
either here or there but basically
politically he's finished and I should
imagine that personally he's he's now in
a sort of bit of a difficult situation
um because of a historic
sort of mistake which you know if you
were in a court of law what would it be
and would it even be sexual assault I
don't know or you know it could just be
a cat-handed attempt at seduction but
we're a very judgmental Society now and
you know any whiff of this sort of thing
is is basically spells the end for
someone
um you know a lot of my readers I wrote
about I wrote about my own experience of
having my breast grouped at number 10 at
a party and a lot of movies has written
in to say that similar things happen to
them they didn't find it offensive they
didn't find it debilitating they just
told the person to stop being so
ridiculous and sort of slap whatever
just you know push them away
it's it's about how we deal with these
things and there's a lot of um debate
around it it is a huge debate
yes and just to say that Daniel korski
said again today in his statement um he
called it a false and unproven
allegation talked about the pressure on
his family and his the inability to get
a fair hearing for his message his
campaign message made it impossible for
his campaign to carry on so he's still
denying the incident um Kevin your
thoughts you you were you were making
some faces I have to say well well Sarah
spoke
yeah well Daisy Goodwin said she's
written about it because Daniel corski
was posing as somebody who's going to
make London safer for women and her own
experience was not that I accept the
denials from him but you've got to
decide who who you believe but just
listen to Sarah Sarah in the old days
when I used to go courting uh trying to
seduce somebody I can't imagine at my
place of work
mistaking uh a signal and grabbing
somebody's breast I just don't get out
of it you might ask them out for a for a
drink or come and watch Sunderland uh
play a football or something but you
know you know I'm sure that was very
popular scenario she has outlined how
that could be anything other than a
grope and uh an assault
yeah but I don't know because I think I
think the thing is that it's it you know
I I mean people's people's seduction
techniques vary don't they so you know
you don't know you might have got the
wrong end of the stick and he off
obviously overstepped a mark and at the
time she said what the hell do you think
you're doing and he stopped so he
clearly had overstepped him up and he
shouldn't have been doing it in that
situation but people do stupid things
don't they and I I what I don't
understand what I'm not sure is whether
the punishment fits the crime in this
instance I don't know because he hasn't
had any kind of scrutiny of you know
there's been no attempt you know there's
no criminal uh investigation or anything
this is absolutely trial by media and
it's just one person's word against
another and you know I think we had to
be a bit careful here Kevin because I
could say to you know I could write an
article in the newspaper saying I had
lunch with that Kevin McGuire the other
day and he touched my knee and you know
you would be finished even if it wasn't
even if it was not sure
what I there are no Sarah did I
there are lots of women who are
genuinely sexually assaulted in the most
appalling way